most people as far as i can see aren't
introverts their friends just suck it's
not about the fact that you don't like
to be around people you love being
around people when they're the people
that get on with you the problem you
have is a lot of the people that are
around you kind of suck you need to find
better friends
what's happening people welcome back to
the show it is a 400 000 subscriber q a
episode which is insane you already know
that i love you all i gushed far too
much on the 500th episode so i'm gonna
save that one for today i asked on my
instagram and on twitter and youtube and
locals for questions and we got hundreds
so i've tried to condense them down a
lot of them were similar so i've tried
to bundle bunches of them together if
your question didn't get answered then i
think 450 is probably only a couple of
weeks away
so just
hold on until then and ask it again
let's get into it
nah
elfer look up front before i get started
i suck at saying these names your all of
your usernames are terrible almost all
of them and i'm gonna butcher them
okay just
put up with it
nah niall for
uh do you think you give off less lad
vibes than when you started the podcast
yes absolutely uh
coming into the podcast i just finished
love island i was a club promoter for
10 years
12 years and i'd really sort of
maximized that side of me right the
professional party boy thing the big
name on campus person
and
yeah i think
it's just time to grow up like you see
this with guys they get to the end of
their 20s and they realize like i
probably should start acting at least a
little bit like an adult now uh and
swearing less is also something that
i've tried to do
uh it just i don't like the way that it
sounds it's good to use when you need to
emphasize something or when you're
having a bro chat
but
less swearing less lady vibes generally
that's the direction i've gone in
billy brostowski
i've watched your growth on youtube and
it's clear that you've made a conscious
commitment likely in place of other
ideas and interests what is your advice
to someone who wants to commit to an
idea in the same way but has trouble
zeroing in on what it should be
avoid
trying to be a perfectionist right
perfectionism is procrastination
masquerading as quality control all that
you need to do is find anything and
commit to it the best part of this
strategy is the committing bit not the
choosing bit now you can commit to
something and find down the line that it
was the wrong thing to do but that is
better than just spinning your wheels
and doing nothing now if you're a little
bit later in life you should be
exploiting more than you're exploring
but most people that watch this channel
have probably still got quite a few
years ahead of themselves so just do a
thing do whatever is the closest
approximation of what right now feels
like something that could be good for
you to commit to and just do that commit
to
publishing one sub stack article a week
for the next three months and see what
happens and you will learn so much just
by doing that or commit to finding a
partner or commit to getting a promotion
at work jordan peterson says find one
thing in life and commit to it as hard
as possible and see what happens
almost all of the games come from the
committing to the thing not from the
thing itself
most of the insights that i've learned
about the show have come from being
narrow and deep on one thing rather than
anything particular about the show
itself
next one david fuller how many
subscribers do you have
thank you david if you don't know david
he's from rebel wisdom uh no relation
but
uh he's a very good friend uh right now
four thousand four hundred thousand
four hundred and twenty three thousand
three hundred and sixty five see when
it's a big number like that it's hard
for me to say uh also just not used to
talking about the size of the channel
when it's this big four hundred and
twenty three thousand three hundred and
sixty five
it's a lot of people
hi
uh jordan pettit what happened to the
bear on your bed when you moved and the
stack of books in the corner so the bear
is still on my bed i think he should
still be there unless the cleaner has
moved him and the stack of books in the
corner interesting um this is
the closest approximation that i've
managed to find in america to what i had
before i'm actually getting one that's
going to be a little bit taller it's
going to go up to about here that'll be
done pretty soon i have no books in
america so if anyone has any suggestions
or wants to send some books uh please do
because i need about 100 or maybe 70 i
think to fill
the entirety of this thing uh
yeah but all of those books are still
there they're just not here with me
a l if traps aren't gay then is sex with
a pantomime horse bestiality or a
threesome
um
[Laughter]
well
presumably the pantomime horse is
you're only going to be able to get to
the person at the back
uh unless the horse is somehow doing
something to itself with inside of its
own skin i think it's bestiality i think
it's larping bestiality it's the safest
type of bestiality that you can do
shelby let's go
what
who would you want to have on the
podcast the most
uh
well
last time someone asked this on the 350
q a i said jocko and then jocko happened
so um
sam harris is on the list uh i really
really
enjoy his work it would be a different
type of conversation again for me
naval is obviously one that would be up
there i
i think goggins for one of the big
productions that we do i think that
goggins would be
again just that level of intensity that
grittiness that realness being able to
see that face up close and and really
sort of dig into him for two and a half
hours i think that would be pretty
special so we've put it out into the uh
podcasting universe now and we'll see if
we can get uh goggins at some point this
year
can i even say can i even say this
username
the pakistani nuns
the
the pakistani nuns
would you get andrew tate on the podcast
uh so me and tate have been
uh talking for a long time i've been
familiar with his work for ages we've
got each other on whatsapp we've
communicated a fair bit
maybe we'll see
hold on tight for that
[ __ ] username
ec were you a club promoter in newcastle
at riverside club i think i may have
seen you there yes that was me stood
outside with a huge afro and a uh dean
put a photo of me with an afro up here
uh a huge afro and
freezing outside yes uh chris pedroza
well deserved question have you been
asked to go on rogan yet uh no i have
not uh we've never met in person but you
did follow me on instagram uh last week
this weekend just gone he did follow me
on instagram which
i guess is
a good sign
syriac how did you manage to get a us
visa what was the process like
um long it is the portfolio that i
submitted was 700 pages so it was about
three inches thick and i needed
signatories of people from within the
industry
it's a very very difficult process to
get into this country legally and
actually be able to work but uh the 01
visa is phenomenal you can be here for
up to three years bank account social
security number health insurance all
that stuff
uh it's pretty good it's just the
barriers to entry are huge anyone that
wants to
get an o1 visa uh
leshatch philippa is the attorney
company that i used and they are
outstanding they only deal with ones and
they make the process unbelievably slick
literally just linked him in with ali
abdal ley hatch philippa you can just
google them online uh jay continent how
short is michael mallis really he's not
that short actually he gets away with a
lot and
is able to be mean because he is
small-ish but he's not that small uh
certainly not as small as he is mean um
not that not that short just like a
little bit smaller
uh not risley mobile you only get one
novelism what do you choose
take no one's word for it
someone asked him if you could describe
if you could give life advice in five
words take no one's word for i guess
that's six six words take no one's word
for it just means to me
that
a lot of the things
that are
default desires or social norms uh some
of them are there for a reason but it's
worth testing them for yourself just to
see
tagus 100 do you feel at home insecure
within the podcasting sphere or do you
feel some form of imposter syndrome and
find yourself comparing modern wisdom to
other podcasters and negatively
self-reflecting
good question yeah um
i do feel competent now i can sit down
with a peterson or a human or a jocko or
whatever
and feel like i'm supposed to be here
we've worked so hard on this show it's
been
500 videos 500 episodes in four and a
half years
with a two-person team basically in on
the publishing side
i feel like i've earned the spot of
where we are i still think i still feel
like the channel is wildly
undersubscribed nothing's changed right
nothing's changed in the last pretty
much
two years apart from a little bit of
better camera quality and me refining a
bit of questioning
so it always felt like we had sort of
latent capacity or leverage or
or ability that just wasn't being
recognized and it's cool like it's nice
to have people that have followed the
channel from
1 000 subscribers and now it's this big
thing and lots of people listen to it
and it's still the same guests are still
similar conversations are still similar
very cool um
when it comes to the imposter syndrome
stuff it is difficult not to
feel a little bit out of place when
you're speaking to somebody that's so
well known or who's got so much reach or
is so well regarded within the industry
um but for the most part i'm i'm getting
a lot better with that um
self-reflection negative self-talk
that's calming down a lot and that's
just a good lesson i think generally for
anybody that's doing any pursuit and
doesn't feel like they're good enough or
is in an industry that is kind of um
has some pretty beastly admirable people
in it over time you're as long as you're
consistent you're going to become that
beast to somebody else like everyone is
a monster in someone else's eyes because
that's all relative unless you're the
person unless you're rogan right unless
you're the number one podcaster in the
world there is always someone that's
going to be above you so you're always
going to have a degree of comparison
between them but that's getting less
which is
nice it's a very nice change
phoenix do you have any advice thoughts
or insights for aspiring youtubers what
is your learning and creating process
how do you strive and improve i'm gonna
answer one of those uh advice thoughts
and insights for aspiring youtubers
learn how the algorithm works learn how
to design thumbnails learn how to do
titling um be consistent with what it is
that you talk about be as open and
vulnerable as possible be as honest as
you can
and talk about stuff that you're
interested in like consistency is born
out of you genuinely wanting to do
something if consistency is one of the
most important things to do to be a good
content creator online then
you need to do something that doesn't
feel like effort because that's going to
enable consistency the most
and other than that there's a physics
right to the platform that you kind of
just need to understand i've always
sucked on instagram like i i don't
really understand growth strategy you
look at someone like james smith right
he's just a
engine on instagram and then he wanted
to do tick-tock so he got a million
followers on tik tok in six months or
something um i've never really
understood stuff in that way but
youtube's the first platform that i
actually spent a lot of time
understanding like i say kind of the
laws of nature of how it works in terms
of just what what's good and what's not
so much of it comes down to
packaging of the content and the way
that you're playing around with those
laws of nature rather than the actual
content quality itself this is presuming
that you've got the content quality to
begin with like if you're talking about
rubbish stuff no one's going to watch or
listen or come back
but
a lot of people feel like they're not
getting the recognition that they want
or need and
that to me if you're confident that your
content is better than the results that
you're getting from it
there's a problem with how you're
playing the game
uh rather than the effort that you're
putting in and the quality of your
content
uh goku black can you please consider
getting muhammad hijab on the podcast
um
so i know that he's
huge in the
islam space online i don't quite know
what i would speak to him about i'm not
massively familiar with islam
i feel like he's maybe touched on some
evolutionary psychology stuff and some
dating dynamic stuff
i have seen some videos of him where
he's
i don't know i haven't seen him be
non-confrontational
with many
guests or
with many of the people that i'm
familiar with uh and
to bring someone on
if if he was to start shouting about
islam and stuff like that i'm like well
i bro this isn't my thing but if there's
something that you think that we've got
common ground on that we could have an
interesting discussion about that'd be
cool like the guy absolutely crushes in
that space and
you know his conversation with jordan
peterson i thought was really cool it
was an interesting one so
yeah
i would consider it as long as we could
find something that we could talk about
what is more important saving our
species by getting our genetics off this
planet or saving the planet from our
species uh saving our species by miles
right the the planet cannot
exist with the degree of protection that
most environmentally focused people want
it to have unless humans are still going
if you decide to
leave all of you all of the
natural world to suffer whatever
catastrophe natural or otherwise decides
to hit it uh
that's going to cause far more suffering
than if humans are still around the
priority has to be human first like
human flourishing is the most important
thing now
if you were to say
what's so special about humans we should
let the entire planet just be back to
itself humans are a curse on this world
we do not have the same
view
of value when it comes to sentient life
right i see
the kind of
flourishing
and
enjoyment
and
fulfillment that humans can get as more
valuable than that of a
ant or a dog even
and this gets borne out right if you had
any animal on the planet or a human and
a car was going to hit one of them
anybody that has any sense is going to
choose for it to hit the animal right
why well because humans inherently have
more value because we have greater
capacity for suffering and greater
sentience than everything else so for me
you can not only
focus on what has to be or what in my
belief should be the
most important animal to save ourselves
but also you can then use the fact that
you've saved us to save other animals to
bioengineer the uh the world so that
it's still habitable to take them off
planet to create backups of their
species and dna coding and sequencing
and all that stuff i mean we could
literally save if if you got it right
you could sequence every animal from now
until the end of time and that would
mean that none of them ever go extinct
right and ever even if they would have
gone extinct naturally we could save
them if we're not here we can't do any
of that jonah capros could you connect
andrew human to jordan peterson i think
that would be a great conversation with
you as a moderator could you please be
that bridge between them for all of us
anyways thanks chris for adding
incredible value to the world thank you
thank you jonah uh they already know
each other they've already been talking
i don't know whether it's for an episode
but they've already been chatting so
they don't need me to peterson human do
not need me
to to step in and connect
them to anybody else they're super hot
[ __ ] but
uh that would be cool to moderate it i
would be very interested to see what
they'd talk about because
those two worlds really don't
you know i haven't heard peterson talk
about uh life hacks and biological
optimization all that much uh and
hearing andrew get into some more
existential philosophical stuff as well
i think would be great that'd be a good
conversation
kristin
demosky can you share your skincare
routine
face
as if as if there's
a skin i've got a skincare routine for
things that aren't my face um
uh yes i've used the same moisturizer
for
12 years now it's clarins for men super
moisture gel it is kind of expensive and
you do go through it kind of quickly
it's about 30 pounds
now they've put the price up to about 40
pounds and you'll get through maybe a
bottle every
month and a half something like that and
i used the face wash as well and that's
all i've used i got this piece of advice
from a friend's ex-girlfriend david
breton if you're listening it was from
your ex mrs and she basically said that
the number one hack for not aging is to
just start moisturizing as soon as you
can and i'm pretty sure she told me that
when i was
20 or 21 and i just from that day have
always had that's the bet that's the
number one hack for guys at least girls
you probably need more complex stuff
than i can teach you about
but for guys just find a moisturizer
that works with your skin and just
continue to use it and just lock
yourself in for the long haul
it seems to work it genuinely does
uh kentucky bound would you consider
having the liver king on your podcast
lots of stigma around him but i think if
you sat down and had to chat with him
you'd find him to be a really
interesting person lots of good to be
heard in his message regardless of the
savage organ devouring thanks chris love
the pod man yeah sure uh he has dm me
we've been speaking over dm a little bit
and i've been speaking to one of the
guys in his team uh so maybe um i
haven't seen anybody really push back
against him
at all
so
that would be one that i would have to
prepare for uh pretty tightly and i
would probably want to
i'd probably want to really really try
and dig into his background why he's
doing the things that he's doing but
it'd be an interesting conversation and
i mean he's
liver king is the andrew tate of fitness
at the moment i think it's like a a
professional troll that is just crushing
every piece of content that he's
associated with
uh
juan
i've butchered that uh do you take
creatine yes i do five grams every day
by jake daniel have you brought up
cosmic skeptics argument for veganism
with michaela or jordan peterson uh i
looped alex and michaela in together and
they have struggled to record a podcast
i want to say four times now i can't
remember if it's alex on michaela's or
michaela and alex's uh they're having a
nightmare scheduling but i'm pretty
confident that conversation will happen
and it'll be really funny like those
those two guys will get on well i know
they already get them well um so that'll
be sweet um given cosmic skeptic's
influence on you why aren't you vegan by
jake daniel again
really good question um my
my diet my dietary habits are at odds
with my ethics i i believe that
uh farming
almost all farming of animals is causing
suffering
and i don't want to cause suffering in
the world
but the main reason that i'm not vegan
is convenience right i
simply
it is a high price to pay for me to
change the way that i eat for me to try
and supplement the protein that i need
to get in in order to sustain the
performance that i want
by
not being plant by not eating meat
products right if i was to go
plant-based that would be a lot more
difficult
and i think that's the main reason that
a lot of people go vegan or don't go
vegan sorry if you gave most people the
opportunity
to switch from their current diet to an
equivalent diet in terms of
macronutrients and taste
that didn't cause animal suffering i
don't know anybody that wouldn't choose
that why wouldn't you choose that it's
the hurdles that you need to get over
and i think
if i was to advise the vegan community
at large without obviously coming to me
for my expert advice on dietary
requirements
i would say um an introductory
course of some kind a a way to advise
people so that they can get into
veganism in a more easy way would make a
huge difference i think that the lack of
uptake is more down to uh barriers to
entry like literal barriers to entry of
lifestyle change rather than a pushback
ethically for most people
uh shivam when are you having naval you
tell me dude like i
the guy is a digital ghost for the most
part i'm pretty sure he made his
uh
twitter go
private recently i haven't seen much
from him in terms of tweets
but the dude's super busy and
i
i would love to have him on he is one of
the most interesting thinkers and that
if you haven't heard it joe rogan and
naval is still the best podcast that
i've ever heard it is the number one
podcast i've ever heard and i must have
listened to it maybe 10 times now um the
man's spectacular but he's also
incredibly difficult to get a hold of
and he sticks to
his principles right he
will not
he said he doesn't want to go back onto
a podcast for a very long time after
rogan because he doesn't feel like he
has anything new to say and he doesn't
want to do podcasts where he says the
same thing twice ever
so
a while uh something tells me that i'll
be
in the queue behind rogan as well
claire mcleod any specific tips or hacks
you found useful for recovery from your
achilles injury practical physical or
mindset thank you uh
physical i stuck to exactly what my
physio told me to do to the letter i
reckon i probably did between 90 and 95
percent compliance on rep range on
frequency on rest on on everything um i
also used some peptides bpc157 and tb500
with the two that i used um
they seemed to be great i
don't intend on split testing it by
rupturing my achilles again and not
using those but
in
my experience of them bpc157 and tb 500
seem to be brilliant
mindset wise i read and listened to a
lot of stoicism during that time ross
edgeley's book
the art of resilience i think it's
called
whatever the one about him swimming
around the uk was and the obstacle is
the way by ryan holiday they were pretty
big influences i watched uh andy
murray's documentary resurfaced on
amazon prime that was sent to me uh by a
couple of uh athlete friends sam
billings who plays for england cricket
he sent it to me and he said it really
helped him when he had an injury it
really is you know when it comes to
mindset i think realizing that it is a
long-term process that you're doing and
also surrounding yourself with other
people that can be virtually or
physically who have gone through bad
injuries and come out the other side
with a positive mindset huge difference
let's talk
you talk you you took fluency i think
that means you talk fluently you talk
very fluently how did you develop this
uh thank you it is something that i've
been working on especially since i
started this the show um
i always had uh
i was always all right talking i guess
all race
but i worked with a speech coach a guy
called miles usher
from speakwell and um
i started working with him because i
wanted to nail my tedx talk and he
identified a ton of
diction issues that he didn't like in
the way that i spoke
and we just worked on getting rid of
some of those so still now i have a tiny
tiny lisp and working away at that was
one of the things so i have a
bunch of tongue twisters that i do that
i haven't been doing enough uh recently
sorry miles but
um those working on pronouncing my
consonants so
people that don't know what the accent
from the north of england is like we
drop our t's a lot so instead of butter
we would say butter and it's just a lazy
way of talking
but if you're speaking to other people
from the northeast of the uk it's fine
if you're trying to
communicate with people that maybe
english isn't even their first language
probably less fine so
worked on a bunch of that i developed it
by finding a coach by working at it
pretty consistently for a long time and
by being intentional so every time i was
speaking out with friends every time i
was speaking on a podcast i was thinking
about that one of the problems that i
have is that when i focus on the way
that i speak the things i say become
less interesting because it's there's
more friction right between my mind and
my mouth because i'm being more
deliberate with the way that my mouth
makes the sounds
and learning out loud i don't get to do
practice sessions with podcasts every
single time that i practice it gets
published for the entire internet to
criticize uh so that's kind of i guess
an interesting
dynamic but even with that you can do
like a little bit of work and then pull
it back and do a little bit of work and
pull it back and
it seems to be going okay
nemesis nah
you did mention having a dog one day
which breed do you fancy and why a
retriever
you got it golden it's got to be a
golden right it it simply has to be a
beautiful
angelic golden boy or golden girl call
campbell what guest or subject area do
you find the most exciting to prepare
research for
and discuss
last few months man i've been loving
this evolutionary psychology stuff and
the dating dynamics um there was
a guy
who came up to me in the gym and in
austin and asked what the reason for the
focus was
on dating recently and i i really
love evolutionary psychology um
the apo understood the universe by steve
stewart williams and the moral animal by
robert wright are two of my favorite
books of all time this love seeing the
way that we're programmed and one of the
easiest
displays of that i suppose
is the way that we show up in
relationships in dating the dating
dynamics and the sexual marketplace and
stuff
that being said i would
i would say that
i'm starting to
maybe move a little bit beyond just the
dating dynamics stuff and into
i don't know trying to mediate between
two
two different groups so
louise perry nina power and mary
harrington are three examples of where
i've tried to bring a woman on to get a
woman's perspective of what's going on
nomikates when she was talking about
incels i know that loads of people don't
like the idea of a woman
woman splaining about dating to men
but i've learned a ton from them and
trying to bridge that gap a little bit
more i think is is what's important for
the red pill world or manosphere space
whatever you want to call it
um and that's hopefully what second wave
manosphere
red pill will be it'll be much more
uh communicative it'll be much more
collaborative between men and women
and if i can nudge it toward that then
that would be it but that's that's what
i've been super enjoying researching and
preparing for recently
and god knows what it'll be in
three months time or six months time
it'll be something completely different
and
you will all be along for the ride and
forced to learn about
e-foiling or
a professional volleyball or whatever it
is that i've got
addicted to uh inexorable after four
years of podcasting what
surprised you most about the ride um
how long it takes for
uh momentum to be gained online i think
me and dean have always said that the
channel felt undersubscribed uh i'm sure
some people think it's oversubscribed
but it always felt like we would we were
putting a lot of work in and and it
wasn't really being seen online or
recognized by the algorithm uh and the
most surprising thing i guess is just
how talented a lot of people are and how
much good content creating there is out
there and yet how little of it makes it
to anywhere close to even where we've
got to and there's still a [ __ ] ton of
headroom above us so
good quality always wins out but it
takes a hell of a lot of time so i guess
the the pace that things go out like
it's nothing no if you watch if you look
at the graph
of the plays from modern wisdom it is
completely flat basically and then
there's just this huge hockey stick and
yet two years ago i thought it had been
completely flat and i was already in the
hockey stick and it always that's what
an exponential curve looks like right
every time you scale out it just looks
the previous month looks poultry in
comparison
um
the amount of patience that you need to
have is the thing that surprised me the
most
nicole q have you considered doing a
coaching program for podcast hosts it
appears you've put thought and effort
into your hosting skills have value to
offer here yeah i have i have um
genuinely considered this doing a
podcast mastery
cohort based course or perhaps even a
passive one it's the thing that i've got
the most skill and experience in i think
in the world except for club promo uh
and the market for people that want to
become club promoters at the level that
i was at is pretty small um i have
considered it quite seriously um
maybe we'll see
if people want that i don't know
leave a comment or something and
i'll get ben to tally them up and
if there's loads maybe it'll push me
slightly more toward doing it
cosmic skeptic hi alex uh does
transcendental idealism offer a
plausible account of the nature of
spatial extension
mate you
you're not impressing anybody it it just
makes you sound like somebody that has
never had sex that's all that that
question does so i i don't know i don't
know what you mean
please go outside
animal baits what kind of conversations
do you have at parties uh chris you know
exactly what sort of conversations i
have at parties because i've had them
with you
and
we stand around a table
at a party filled with interesting
good-looking people and
weird anyone out that comes within about
10 feet of what we're talking about uh
we was me and him and one of our friends
called ben out here and austin were
apart he sat stood around a table and we
went from ai sex robots to simulation
theory to our aliens out there to
whether you can crush a watermelon
between your thighs and anybody that
tried to join in was there for about 15
seconds and then just thought it was
just a bit weird this
strange and then left so that's that's
the sort of conversation that i have
uh
pastorinico
what did you have to give up in order to
get to your current position
uh this is
a smart question because it's similar to
what i ask a lot of the guests which is
what is the price you pay for being you
um
a lot of time to be honest like the show
is still so effortful like it is a huge
lift by me and dean uh with assistance
by ben it is
hours and hours and hours and hours
every single week to get the episodes up
and so i guess spare time time with
friends time in the gym uh time in
nature time relaxing outside um trips
away
friend may i would have made more
friends and stuff i suppose um
this this kind of really
rubber meeting the road of why are you
doing the thing that you're doing you
know what are you optimizing for you're
optimizing for just success or growth at
any cost or whatever but at the moment
i'm not far off pushing way too hard and
burning out but i'm just below the
surface of it so i can keep going with
where we're at at the moment
but at some point in future we're going
to need to
get a producer in or or something
because
it's
doing three episodes a week the way that
we do is kind of hard and i'm looking
forward to after having put you know
probably five years of work in
completely solidly at the first three
years of that the first two years of
that being whilst running a business
i'm looking forward to
having a little bit more time to kind of
i don't know do other things or indulge
whilst still the show delivering the way
that it needs to
uh
[Music]
oh my god
lee acted
psychos
[ __ ]
what is the most important difference in
mentality between males and females oh
that is a good question
what is the most important difference
uh i can't give you the most important
but i can give you
one of the very interesting differences
which is that i think in fact here's an
interesting one to go over the top of
all of it i think that a lot of the
differences between men and women come
from motivations rather than capacities
so
on average men and women are mostly the
same at most things right
whether you're talking about their
ability to be nurturing or their upper
body strength there's some differences
there but across most things
most men and women are mostly the same
however they show up in incredibly
different ways so what does that say it
says that it's less to do with capacity
and more to do with motivation
i think 80 percent of the people that
work over 50 hours a week are men
that's got nothing to do with capacity
women have the same number of hours in a
week as men do but they don't choose to
work more than 50 hours
that's a motivation thing like men can
hold a baby just as well as i mean they
can maybe even hold a baby slightly
better better for longer
look at the one rep max of baby holding
men can hold a baby
just as well as women do and yet they
tend not to
so
why well motivation so i think the
biggest differences between men and
women lie in their motivations rather
than in their capacities
any tips for meeting people organically
rather than through dating apps yes read
models by mark manson and he will tell
you that the best place to go is to
think about what is the sort of person
that i'm wanting to meet
where do they go and go there if you're
into chicks that are fit and do crossfit
and have big legs and big bums and stuff
go to a crossfit class go to multiple
different gyms
throughout the month and find the one
that's got all of the hot chicks in or
if you're after a guy that is into
musicals or into books or poetry or
whatever go to a theater or a library or
a book reading or a poetry gig or
something like it's pretty easy if you
want to find someone that has something
that's a core part of their being where
would that sort of person go and just go
there
that's like it is a bit of a no-brainer
is there a mindset
is there a mindset an introvert can have
to make approaching socializing more
bearable um
it is kind of difficult to be honest uh
finding people that you like to be
around is a big part of that most people
as far as i can see aren't introverts
their friends just suck like it's not
about the fact that you don't like to be
around people you love being around
people when they're the people that get
on with you the problem you have is a
lot of the people that are around you
kind of suck or they don't vibe with you
you need to find better friends that's
the easiest solution just and what did
we say before like what is the sort of
friend that you would like to spend your
time around where would that sort of
friends spend their time
go there that would be my best piece of
advice
spooner sean what have you learned about
yourself since hitting record on episode
number one
uh episode number one was with a guy
rowing naked across the atlantic uh
uh four and a bit years ago in my old
office in newcastle
um have i learned about myself dudes
like
everything the
personal development on self
understanding in the last four and a
half years has been supercharged since
before then
um
i guess one of the main things i've
learned is that i'm a lot more confident
than i thought i was um
i just had never had something that had
reflected
back to me
i always had this excuse when it came to
club promo that the success that we had
wasn't mine it was
like a manipulation of the market in a
way i was too many degrees of freedom
removed
from the success that the business had
to be able to feel like it was mine to
bear right that my ability on my
capacity had actually caused something
good to happen
uh and i think that this is maybe
anyone that's got a self-critical mind
will find a way to
explain away the
things that they've done in their
achievements they'll
blame it on look or timing or whatever
and um
since doing something where my
effort and input is directly
related to the results uh and not just
in terms of plays but the messages that
i get that inform me far more than the
number of plays and stuff
that has really changed a lot because
i've finally got something where i think
oh wow like i actually do have
competency here if i put in work i can
see the results which i always knew from
the gym but it was i don't know
that was a big thing i think i'm more
confident than i need i'm more confident
than i knew i just needed something that
would kind of
reflect it back at me
tommy mcnee are you still doing club
promoting uh no i'm not so i'm still
right now i am still a partner at voodoo
that may change in the not too distant
future uh but darren my business partner
is still crushing it in newcastle he's
got his bar 2020 if you're in newcastle
and you want to go out on the big market
go to 2020 say that i sent you said here
from modern wisdom and i'm sure that
he'll do something nice for you
and all of this stuff that we've done
jamie and keira and all of the guys that
have
been at the company long term are still
crushing it i love
that world but it was uh it was time for
me to
take on a new challenge i think
uh
will you get andrew tate on your podcast
one day uh i didn't combine these two
together dude i i
i think that what tate's doing at the
moment i mean it's it's having watched
him for so long it is
wild to see that the world is only just
kind of
getting a hold of how interesting that
guy is like say what you want about what
tate does right he's an interesting guy
to watch and he's a very compelling
person to see on the internet you do not
need to agree with him but you watched a
lot of his content so
really is weaponizing eyes and attention
at the moment in a way that
very few other people are except for
maybe liver king i i reckon that's it
man i reckon liver king is the andrew
tate of the fitness world they're both
professional trolls they both do not
care about what the world thinks about
them and they're both making a [ __ ] ton
of money
there it is
uh
george j kennedy not a question but i
can't wait for the day that you go on
jre
uh
me too i need to find something to talk
to him about first uh lucy lucy vian
vyan what are you unwilling to feel um
lazy
or
like i haven't fulfilled my potential
that's probably the most accurate one
i'm unwilling to feel like i haven't
fulfilled my potential and that's one of
the things that drives me forward it
should be more positive i know
me that did the episode right i did the
episode
with dr benjamin hardy about the gap and
the gain about the fact that you need to
be living in the game not in the gap you
need to be comparing yourself to who you
were yesterday not who you want to be
tomorrow or who somebody else is in 10
years time
but
at the moment i still really struggle to
deal with
days when i don't
fulfill everything that i should where i
don't
perform in the way that i want to
so i'm willing to fill that and i do
everything to try and avoid it uh mcdo
can everyone please just change
your usernames for the day that you
submit the questions to something which
is easy for me to pronounce because
i i actually feel like somebody that's
trying to eat food and speak at the same
time
what
what's your training split like and
weight
you use for big lifts
training split at the moment is about
six days a week and it is a
kind of like a push-pull legs i suppose
and then on the other
few days i will do uh spinal
rehabilitation stuff from my coach larry
over active life rx
uh and that is to continue to try and
fix some of the problems that i've got
some of the pain and discomfort that
i've got on my lower back uh weight that
i use for big lifts i'm really not
pushing that hard at the moment so i'm
not squatting i'm not dead lifting i
haven't done for a very long time uh
when it comes to
i don't know the heaviest stuff that i
move around
between 40
between 40 kilos and 50 kilos on
dumbbell press
benching at whatever two plates aside
ish
um but there's not that many big lifts
that are doing at the moment
uh grange gram
thoughts on adam heading back into love
island mr collard how are you
i think that it's
hilarious uh i think that it's
surprising
i think
it makes sense uh that they would do it
because for all of the previous
islanders kicking up a first and saying
we were told that that nobody was able
to go back in and and and now he
why why aren't i and it's like look
the guy
obviously
fits the narrative that they're trying
to put across of
uh
whatever
what's it called flying the ointment
and
he's crushed it like he's gone on he's
caused one of the guys to leave within
the space of one or two days
uh he's
made a ton of uproar and everyone's
talking about it like you needed someone
in there that was going to be the bad
guy he's not going to win there is no
way that adam can win but i think he'll
have a lot of fun while he's in there
and i'm looking forward to catching up
with him when he comes out it's
hilarious
uh
marco stott no phones in bedroom when
you wake at 3am what do you do instead
of audiobooks or podcasts uh
so i've got kindle next to my bed i tend
to very rarely wake up at 3am i think if
you're waking up at 3am
something is going wrong with either
your day or your night
and you probably need to look at your
routine because there is no reason if
you're getting up at a normal time and
going to bed at normal time and getting
enough sunlight and
food and training and social contact and
all the rest of it you shouldn't be
waking up at 3am but if i was to wake up
at 3am i would do
i would try and go back to sleep
right
i
wouldn't do anything else other than try
to sleep and
hope for the best
okay that that username literally
doesn't have any vowels in it
do you get botox no i don't just told
you
my uh skincare regime form a face
uh sold you to that
melanin
melaninfit.pg
just a fan from across the ocean you are
awesome i mean how do you keep your face
serious
i don't know what that means
i have no idea what that means the the
bro
jack comics
uh how well would you handle yourself in
a debate politics red pill veganism
ethics etc
uh there's not
a ton of things that i
would make an unbelievably
um
partisan stance
on
like i don't i i'm not going to stand
here and
have some huge argument about
conservatism versus liberal values right
i don't care all that much the same goes
for veganism like i think that there are
elements that i take from both sides uh
ethics as well i'm happy to have a
discussion but like a hardcore debate
i'm not sure when it comes to red pill
stuff i have a alright bit of an
understanding when it comes to that uh
there was a girl who did
some reaction video
moon cat i think she's called and um she
did i debunked the entire manosphere
video and she used maybe three seconds
of a clip from us she didn't mention the
channel at all i actually thought the
video was was pretty good i'd be really
interested to have a discussion with her
because she seems pretty reasonable she
seems well researched she's british as
well um so i'd be interested to have a
discussion with her around it but even
with that like the concept of going into
something is a debate is that somebody's
got a position they need to convince the
other person of i'd be much more
interested in going okay so why is it
that you think this particular way why
is it that upon seeing similar evidence
to the stuff that i've seen that we've
come out with very differing points of
view i'm not trying to convince anybody
of anything really apart from the fact
that you don't need to live your life by
default you can live it by design that's
something i'm trying to convince
everybody of but there are very few
universal truths that
i i think that you need to have strong
opinions loosely held not loose opinions
strongly held right and that means i'm
always open to changing my mind about
stuff and i'm like chronically aware of
my own fallibility so
yeah maybe maybe i think i'd do pretty
well when it comes to discussing
eve psych stuff and dating dynamics but
beyond that i'd just be interested in
having a discussion
andrea levy what are your top three
favorite books
i have a reading list of 100 books that
you should read before you die and you
can get it if you go
here
and if you go to chriswilex.com
books uh three that everybody should
read the forgotten highlander by
alistair ercart
um
endurance by alfred lansing
and
don't trust your gut by seth stephens
davidowitz that isn't even in the 100
books list
nate witt pt will you be attending ifs
2022 in lisbon
maybe
uh i'm currently speaking to luke one of
the guys that runs it and james smith
who is on the show pretty soon and we're
going to be discussing whether i can get
myself over from texas to go to lisbon
for that
last year was
a lot of fun and uh
i was bouncing around with a gram and a
half of mushrooms in me for most of the
weekend so
it was very enjoyable andy lacey why is
it important to share what we learn why
do we feel the need to help people this
is a cool question so
my belief is that
a lot of the things that we go through
in life that hurt us that are challenges
that we
in retrospect maybe wish hadn't happened
you can transcend the suffering of those
by teaching other people how to get past
them as well
this thing came up against you you
thought it was going to end you and it
didn't because you got through it and
it's not going to get the other people
either because you're going to use what
you went through in order to expedite
their success or help them to avoid
pitfalls
and
i know it's it's a it's a really good
way of sticking your middle finger up at
parts of life or people in your life
that have done things that you wish that
they hadn't it is
one of the best ways to transcend
resentment or bitterness or whatever it
might be you take it's like a
it's like alchemy right you take
something that was really really painful
or uncomfortable or difficult or
embarrassing or saddening or traumatic
or whatever
and then you turn it into something that
makes the world better like that's
[ __ ] power that's power
else
what's your criteria for choosing guests
the same as it has been since the first
episode which is anybody that i find
interesting
this show is a sequence of conversations
with people that i think are interesting
and you guys get to listen in like
that's the way it works i
don't want to be
trying to choose guests based on
i don't know someone else's idea of who
i should be talking to who would make
for a responsible discussion now
that's not to say that there aren't
times when you need to bring other
voices on to learn more about the
conversation you've had let's say that i
have someone that's anti fossil fuels
having someone that's pro fossil fuels
means that i get to understand more but
if i'm not interested
it's not going to happen okay
the show is
my curiosity being dragged forward and
if i had somebody on the show that i
didn't care about what they were saying
it's going to be an awful conversation
so the criteria is
who am i curious about and what have
they got to say
rick falder any luck finding a cricket
team in texas no not yet so if you run a
cricket team in texas please reach out
lisa smythe not a question saws you are
awesome
you are awesome lisa
luge
lugexo
have you considered writing your own
book just a curious thought
um so
yep there is a
i've had a book offer i've had a couple
of book offers
but
at the moment we i just don't have any
spare time the show three episodes a
week is it eats me alive and
if i was to write a book now it would be
i it would not be anything close to the
quality that i would want it to be
because i would be pushing myself way
way way beyond my capacity that's not to
say that it's not going to happen in
future and i know that um
the
um
i know that the publisher would love
that i hurried up that
realization or that delegating of
control so that we could get started but
i think it will happen in fact i'm
almost certain that it will happen it's
just a case of when
mr daniel stevens any theories on why
songs get stuck in people's heads on a
loop i find it happens when i'm tired
so during my research for the huberman
episode he spoke about the fact that
first thing in the morning our brains
are unusually responsive to inputs
and i think that you might be finding
that when you're tired something similar
is happening here too it's the same
reason why i don't listen to music on
the radio alarm clock that i use on the
morning
because if it's any song with any sort
of catchy tune for the next hour that's
all that i can hear looping in my head
uh i mean that might be a me like a my
brain mindfulness problem rather than
music on the radio problem but it's
easier for me to get away from it um yes
unusually responsive to inputs on the
morning and presumably your brain state
is going to be similar when you're tired
on a night time as well
uh josh
sanchez why did you start getting
therapy has it been helpful i'm nervous
to get into it
yeah i mean i've done a bunch of
different things i wouldn't say that i'm
super super well experienced with
therapy i've maybe done 20 sessions or
something in my life
but
the guy that i work with now vinnie
shawman is a hypnotist he's a
performance coach and he is great with
timeline therapy with a bunch of
interpersonal stuff too um
you just simply don't know
what you've got lurking
in your mind that could be holding you
back
and until you start to speak to somebody
like literally we have pts everybody
understands the value of a pt
for getting the body in shape the mind
is infinitely more complex than the body
and yet people don't go to a therapist
when they feel like they need to do some
work
on their mind so i think that's that's
the most compelling uh analogy that i
could use
uh 500 days of caffeine what were your
positive takeaways i think that means
500 days off caffeine uh 500 days of
caffeine would have been the exact
opposite of what i did um
i had better sleep i had uh
no more the most important thing
actually the best takeaway from doing
caffeine free for a year and a half
was that i completely deprogrammed my
need for caffeine it's the same main
takeaway that i learned from
alcohol from going a thousand days
without alcohol was that
a lot of why you take the substance
isn't because of the effect of it it's
because of a compulsion that you have
and
now when i want to have caffeine i do it
hits me like an absolute train so i've
got
uh 90 mig
energy drinks rather than 150 that i
think is in a knocco 200 that would be
in uh like a celsius or 300 that would
be in a bang i've got a 90. it's like a
medium cup of coffee and it still takes
my head off um that's that's the the
best takeaway i no longer need it i can
choose to use it when i want to and when
i do use it it is like rocket fuel
um
how present who presents a better x-risk
russia or china the british public
currently believe they are equal
i would say china i think that
over the next 50 years they're a huge
threat and then in about 50 years time
they become a much less big of a threat
because
the population is just wrecked now like
they just do not have enough young
people to support the old people and in
50 years time all of the current young
people are going to be old people and
there won't be enough more young people
to keep them going young people are the
ones that buy things they're the ones
that make things the ones that actually
keep the economy going
and they're going to be really
struggling but they're going to know
that which means that the next 50 years
are going to be particularly precarious
as they try to future proof themselves
from civilization or demographic
collapse over the
next however long
md performance psychology no question
would love to see you engage with a high
profile muslim on your podcast i'm a big
fan of your work well muhammad hijab has
been suggested i just don't know
i don't know what i would talk to him
about um
like
i know so little
about
islam
like apart from
ramadan and stuff like what am i i just
don't know what i would talk to him
about but i again i'm open to having a
discussion with a high-profile muslim uh
if they want to talk about dating
dynamics or existential risk or
fitness or something
i can't even make that what noise does
the letters k j h e n g r
what like what is that
kish
why slash how did you move to the u.s
why austin uh why was because i would
had i'd done everything there was to do
in the uk and i felt like i needed a
change and i wanted to be somewhere that
was social with good weather with a lot
of fitness and health and wellness and
stuff and i had a ton of friends that
were already here and all of the things
i predicted that would happen have
happened
uh
which makes me my self-righteousness
feels vindicated and super satisfied
ib andy vickers is woke over are we
coming back from the extreme forms of
left and right to being sensible again
so woke isn't over but i do believe that
we've passed peak woke uh i think that
pequok was
around about june or july of 2020 and i
think now if you look at almost anybody
that isn't an insane super lefty they
understand that transiting the kids or
um allowing a toddler to come into
nursery and say that they're a different
gender and encourage them to do that and
not tell the parents i don't know
any person that thinks that that's
genuinely ethical to do
however it is going to take a very long
time for that to happen and we also need
to be careful about too much of a
flip-flop back to the other side where
you could see
right-wing
ideas that are also
pretty bad extreme right-wing ideas
coming through um
yes i think that pequok has
we've reached apogee and we're coming
back down now i think there's a long way
to go and i think that we need to be
concerned about how much we swing back
to
uh
bret jmcc has coveted increased divorce
rates um
maybe
i don't know
someone post this stat below someone
will have this post a stat below if you
know ryan cousteau thoughts on the tate
brothers uh i didn't do a good job of
bundling these together uh they're
interesting guys so i'm what i have to
say
rob vander that's a good one rob vander
now you're in texas do you want to own a
gun in the near distant future i've been
shooting a lot a shot i did some
training i did some competitive shooting
and it is i can completely see why
people think it's fun like these pieces
of machinery are unbelievably precise
and powerful uh and
focus your attention a lot if you've got
a gun in your hand and you're treating
with respect and not waving it around
like a [ __ ]
if you have a gun in your hand you think
about nothing else other than the fact
that you've got good in your hand and
there's not many things you can hold in
your hand that cause that caused that to
happen
uh adam dixon95 how much do you drink
alcohol now i know you took significant
breaks in the past so
over
the course of about five or six years i
was probably sober for maybe four and a
half of them
and
now i will drink pretty infrequently uh
there's a couple of weekends in a row
where i was drinking saturday sunday out
here at pool parties and stuff
but i also have recently done a couple
of month long breaks that i just felt i
needed to do if i wanted to focus on
episodes didn't drink in the lead up to
human or jocko because just cutting out
alcohol makes such a difference to your
mental agility your sleep quality your
recovery everything so
it is just a tool the same as the
pomodoro technique or [ __ ] putting
your phone and do not disturb
it's exactly the same now it's just a
tool that i can drop into and drop out
to drop out of as much as i want
giovanti are you a full-time youtuber
podcaster now what advice would you give
to people in 20s i guess i am a
full-time youtuber or podcaster now it
is the main
passion project it is what i go to sleep
thinking about in the night time it is
what i spend all of my waking hours
working on
uh what advice would i give to people in
the to the people in 20s
what advice would you give to people
give to the people in 20 i don't know i
don't know what i would give to the
people in 20s um what i would say to
people that are in their 20s is work
hard see what your tolerances are for um
high amounts of work
what does too much feel like what does
too little feel like and then that gives
you parameters i know the limits of how
hard i can work and i know just as i'm
about to touch them and then i can back
off which is what i've done consistently
for about two years
the only way that you can know that is
if you've really pushed it too hard and
you can't really afford to find that out
when you're 42 and you've got kids and
why like you can't be burned out because
you've pushed yourself too hard or you
can't be dissatisfied with life because
you're not pushing hard enough learn
those boundaries i think in your 20s
when you've got the freedom to be able
to do it and then that will inform you
moving forward
fire zuma
bro what do you think about people me
who are interested in random subjects
you're my favorite type of people
that's
the the people that only have one
obsession when it comes to curiosity to
me it is so strange like this is one of
the reasons i absolutely love the
podcast modern wisdom
is the show that i would listen to
if i was an audience member because
i feel like everybody has
everybody is a multifaceted human right
we all have tons of things that we're
interested in we
got obsessed about ufc knockout so we
got obsessed about uh 19th century
poetry or we got whatever right there
are tons and tons and tons of things and
with these multi-layered multi-faceted
creatures that have loads of different
interests
why
why not reflect that in the content that
you make
there's this common held
wisdom or whatever in content creation
world especially in podcasting that
you're supposed to niche down niche down
super hard you capture that niche
because you can make a name for yourself
in a small pond much easier than you can
make it in a big pond and then once
you've captured the niche you then
broaden out from there now i know maybe
maybe i've made an error by not doing
that maybe we could have got here to
where we are quicker had i have done
something different
i don't want to do that at all there is
no part of me that wants to spend 150
episodes a year just talking about
dating or just talking about culture
wars or just talking about health and
fitness or philosophy or mindfulness or
mindset or growth or resilience or
anything
i want to be able to talk about all of
them and then if i find something new
like brett johnson the world's most
american fbi's most wanted man and uh
the biggest hacker on the planet i want
to be able to have a conversation with
him and i don't want to bring him on and
have to start asking him about what he
thinks about hypergamy right like
putting everything through one frame or
even a couple of frames just seems it's
boring i don't want to do that i'm
interested in lots of things if you're
interested in lots of things as well
you're probably super interesting
because you can
find common ground with so many more
people that you speak to it's a
superpower it's not it's not a weakness
not having a narrow band of interests is
something that you should be proud of
uh n bolton 13.
do you still keep in contact with anyone
from love island uh so from my season
uh
little bits here and there have bumped
into josh ritchie if that guy is like
anywhere that i go on holiday he josh
ritchie permanently lives on holiday
right and he only lives on holiday in
the places that i'm going to apparently
he was in ibiza when i was in ibiza
twice he was in dubai when i was in
dubai he was in manchester when i was in
manchester
the guy is
everywhere uh john i speak to
very rarely um
[Music]
max we speak
moderately regularly i saw him in
newcastle one of our events toward the
back end of last year um and then
collard
obviously can't keep in contact with him
at the moment because he's on the island
but those are those are the ones
uh
no
no there for the memes one
i am a fan of the red rising series 2
first trilogy ever tried to interview ps
brown so pierce is in my instagram dms
and i will
almost certainly get him on i will
definitely try to get him on once the
new book comes out once book six comes
out
i will definitely try and get him on i
think he's a fascinating human i love
the fact that he takes all of his ideas
from history uh from real battles all of
the naming of the character it's so
immersive if anybody needs a fiction
series right now go and buy red rising
on kindle or buy the book the audio
series is great as well
it is the most addicting series i've
ever anybody that i send it to it should
come with a warning label it should come
with a like warning this product is
highly addictive because it is it's next
level uh yes i will get him on
rory gillespie would you have ben
shapiro on the show yeah sure uh i would
be interested to speak to him
ben a little bit more about his personal
views and stuff culture wars stuff for
me
it's great for um
gaining plays and having a laugh kind of
crazy stuff that you've seen on the
internet but i would be much more
interested in hearing about shapiro's
motivations he works incredibly hard he
was similar to me he was bullied
a fair bit in school
i'd want to know how that informs the
way that he shows up now
uh
loads of stuff i i'd love to find out
about his typical daily routine i'd love
to find out about how he prepares for
episodes there's so many things that
like shapiro particularly would be
really fascinating to talk to about that
no one ever asks him about because
everybody just wants him to
dunk on trans people or whatever and i
think that there's more there's
definitely more to him than that so yeah
hold on
uh
rory gillespie you have asked a lot of
questions and i haven't i'm not i'm not
going to answer them all um
uh do you have plans to update your
reading list what's the best book
currently not on that list yeah i'll do
it eventually
i feel like there's still a lot of
people watching this podcast who haven't
downloaded the reading list yet if you
go to chriswilex.com books maybe i'll
get another one out soon um best book
currently not on that list
um
so i'm reading how to think like a roman
emperor again which is donald robinson's
which is just
amazing
um
probably what i said earlier on um
don't trust your gut by seth stephens
duvidowicz that's great actually the
case against the sexual revolution by
louise perry just outstanding i think
it's out in america now so if you
watched that podcast and you didn't get
the book go and buy louise's book the
case against the sexual revolution
because it's really really good
um
casey ben do you have to ha do you have
to achieve the thing in order to realize
the thing won't make you happy
overall yes i think so i think naval's
right when he says that it is far easier
to achieve our material desires than to
renounce them
um it's much simpler for you to not care
about having a banged-up old car if you
know what it feels like to get inside of
a ferrari there's just an open loop
element of of humans and we are
naturally statusful creatures this
doesn't mean that you can't
do some mindfulness work and reduce your
ego down and stop playing keeping up
with the joneses and and the comparison
game and stuff you absolutely can
but for a lot of things i genuinely
think it might be easier to just to just
do the thing to just achieve the thing
and then you can absolutely let go of it
you can completely transcend it
um
rory gillespie look this is a good
question rory so i'm going to give you
i'm going to give you two but you you've
asked so many questions here how the
[ __ ] did these get through anyway this
is a good question so you can have two
uh best advice you could give to teens
slash young adults who worry about still
being a virgin i'm going to guess that
this is for men um or for guys
dude i wouldn't worry
at all
like especially if you're in your teens
i lost my virginity it's like well into
my 17th year
uh no sorry well into the year of being
17 so my 18th year um
i was hopelessly
lonely and uncool
and
just
you if there had been a who was going to
stay a lifelong virgin
uh
vote at school
it would have almost definitely been me
this is one of the things wheat waffles
i saw him do a conversation with first
man uh not long ago wheat waffles this
big black pill youtuber and uh first man
does red pill stuff
and
one of the things that i haven't heard
talked about much from
people that are worried about still
being a virgin or in cells that are
young is look you do not know what your
future has in store for you
you honestly you don't know how you're
going to look you don't know how
comfortable you're going to be around
other people how social you're going to
be the money that you make the status
that you achieve
that
maybe you turn gay maybe you you become
so comfortable with yourself that you
you just get this animal magnetism or
whatever it might be like you have
it's not literally sound like my parents
you have so much time it doesn't worry
blah it doesn't there's no need to worry
blah blah blah but it's a little bit
more nuanced than that you simply can't
track the trajectory of your life that
well
when you're young everything that's
happening right now feels like that is
all that there's ever going to be
you have no idea of the optionality and
of the different life paths that you
could take downstream from here
just have faith like
almost all people are going to be
completely fine and you're probably
going to be one of them so just don't
obsess over what it is
uh mindful mitch would you fight a polar
bear with three limbs or three what
rottweilers what's your tactic
well i mean it's gonna have to be
a polar bear with two legs and one arm
so i'm fighting a polar bear with one
arm because there's no way that i could
do it with one leg or three rottweilers
i don't know i mean how bad a rottweiler
is
they're the ones that can lock their
jaws around your arm i think
that would suck
i but i mean the polar bear's just going
to maul you alive it's got to be the
rottweilers tactic
i think you come out of the gates hot i
think you come out hot really hot you're
trying a lot of kicking you need to
volley the first one pretty well like as
it's coming towards you're going to have
to time it and you're going to because
you're hopefully going to get it in the
midsection you want to come in with a
lateral kick right around the side that
means its head is going to be perilously
close to your jewels so
nice sort of side kick into the first
one show them that you mean business and
then
from it's just a scrap from there that's
that's the best i've got
reader
one two two six advice for guys in their
30s struggling to find purpose
um
dude i don't know it's
this this was me like
toward the end of my 20s started my 30s
this was me i didn't have something to
contribute to and
for the most part everyone is making it
up um purpose is something that
is really really difficult to to work
out
you'll know when you've got it
when you have a reason to wake up in the
morning
if you wake up
and you want to get out of bed
that's because you've got purpose
purpose comes from
aligning your capacities internally with
demands externally
and
if you are struggling to find it
a change of scenario might help a
two-week holiday somewhere that you've
never been or a trip to see a friend
that you haven't caught up with for ages
like if you're struggling to find it it
means that the current stimulus the
current inputs that you've got aren't
working so
yeah maybe you go away on holiday and
it's totally [ __ ] or maybe you go and
see your friend and he's turned into a
[ __ ] but
you know that the strategy that you're
using at the moment doesn't work and
that one's different so
try and do different things go to
different places meet different people
and when you find something that
approximates anything that you could be
interested in just dedicate yourself to
it and then change from that goes right
back to one of the first questions uh
cameron4987 where next for the podcast
how do you continue to iterate and
progress
i don't know man i mean
400 000 subs is so many it sounds it's a
huge number
uh
i i we always i always hoped that we
would be
up there with
huge shows because i
felt like
i worked hard and the guests that i
brought on were super interesting and
the conversations we had were really
valuable
um i don't really know what's next i
mean continuing to find
more fascinating guests um
getting on more and more big people big
names you know goggins this year would
be unbelievable schultz as well this
year would be unbelievable um
more of the big productions i love them
i think that they look phenomenal i
think that it's the best looking
podcasts on the internet and i will
challenge any person to show me a better
looking podcast the joker willing
podcast is the prettiest podcast that
i've ever seen happy to see other ones
but it is
gorgeous
why not just keep doing that but i just
need to i don't know someone link me
with sam harris someone linked me in
with david goggins someone linking in
with andrew schultz
we'll we'll take it from there uh in
terms of other stuff just
keep platforming people that i think
have got interesting stories this is the
best thing
for almost all of your career as a
podcaster you're riding on the coattails
of other people and slip streaming their
fame and then after a while the power
flips and you can be the person that's a
platform for other people so louise
perry case against the sexual revolution
that episode did a quarter of a million
plays on youtube and a ton on audio as
well
and she got to
number one in gender studies on amazon
and she sent me a screenshot on twitter
and said this is
all because of the episode that we did
like she she must have been able to
track the sales or or something
and um that's so cool for me to get
someone that is they've already done it
right she's super talented the book's
amazing
all that she needed was that signal
amplifying a little bit
that makes me feel
is pretty cool
so continuing to find underground heroes
that nobody knows about and continuing
to find the best and the brightest and
the biggest names
and put unbelievable ridiculous
productions on i want to do a podcast in
the arctic actually we're talking about
this with my producer uh the one that
does the the big episodes colton i'm
going to do a podcast in the arctic so
snowy scene complete flat backdrop maybe
mountains in the background totally
outside you'd have to bring a generator
you'd have to travel out for ages that'd
be that'd be pretty cool
um
navy uh you grew quickly in a short
amount of time what do you think helped
you grow the most at eclipse man like
utilizing clips understanding the
physics of the system on youtube and
stuff uh and just consistency with 500
episodes in is it that quick
that we've grown to 400 000 subs in 500
episodes
like it's not actually that many it's
less than a thousand subs per episode
plus all of the clips on top clips help
that's a big part of it people often
don't want to commit to a full podcast
but they're happy to commit to a short
clip and then from there you've got them
and
they go down but yeah just stay
consistent and if you know that you've
got
a format that works or a talent or
whatever just don't stop
uh in your opinion tom g murray 94 in
your opinion is there an appropriate way
to approach a woman in the gym or is it
a no-go zone depends what sort of gym if
it's a gold's gym where everyone's
training with their earbuds in and doing
glute bridge it's a bit more difficult
if you're in a crossfit gym or a
functional fitness place it is so social
this is why if you like
fitness guys or fitness girls just join
a functional fitness gym because it's so
communal you'll be dating in no time uh
paul nadhirus modern wisdom merch out
soon wouldn't mind a nice blue modern
wisdom tee
yes so we've got designs done by 99
designs and we got some absolute
monsters the the designers are so good
uh so i can't wait we're gonna do that
that'll be pretty soon um i'm gonna
guess t-shirts mostly
hoodies kind of doesn't make sense at
the moment still in the middle of summer
and then maybe some hoodies this winter
but yeah it'll be it'll be happening if
you've got ideas for what you want to
see in them throw it in the comments
uh
christogram
[Music]
621. what's douglas murray like after a
few drinks
spectacular
absolutely spectacular that man
is
a a very very funny person to have at a
dinner i went to the peterson's wedding
and was sat next to him uh we've spent a
bunch of nights in new york drinking
manhattan's until three in the morning
the guy is
a lot of fun uh and he gets
when i drink i don't get any more witty
i get slurry right
douglas somehow gets sharper once he's
had a bit of booze in him i actually
think that he might be a performance
enhancer for him so he might be drinking
before he goes on fox i don't i don't
know
a lot is analyzed into what makes a
happy life how can you sum it up in a
line harry keenan 37
i think naval probably got it pretty
right that
take no one else's word for it
or maybe not maybe
maybe morgan housel look at me
repurposing everybody else this is what
i do i'm not look i've made a career of
being the dumbest person in the room i'm
never going to say one of my ideas am i
gonna say someone else's
um morgan housel has this idea that um
wealth gives you the ability to do what
you want when you want with who you want
for as long as you want and no one can
tell you otherwise
the main thing that i see that's a
common theme with a happy life is
freedom right it's the freedom to do
what you want to do and also the freedom
to know what you want to want
those are the two things
the freedom to be able to do what you
want to do and to know what you want to
want
that's it
see
jefferet what would you tell the chris
williamson with 5k subs back in the day
about your career journey
it's going to happen man
everything that you are doing right now
is
investment in the future and thank you
for doing it
uh harry keenan 37 again no not twice
for you sorry harry
um
ibrahim
mohamud let's get married sure man let's
let's you know let's do it let's do it
uh final one i'll do one more j todd how
much knowledge slash insight do you
retain from interviewing all of your
guests and what are some practical
applications of it
dude it's hard
it is hard having this volume of content
pushed into my face on a weekly basis i
love it um but
i mean there's definitely more that i'm
learning than i can retain or implement
um
tim ferriss has this idea called the
good [ __ ] sticks
and it is the best most freeing way to
think about consuming content like look
you can listen to 10 podcasts in a row
and if nothing stands out
it didn't need to stand out you don't
need to remember it
if you listen to three podcasts in a row
and there's ten things from each of them
that you that are life-changing
that's why like just allow
the
natural evolution of the ideas that you
retain and the ones that hit you and you
you clip or screen record and send to
your friends or take a screenshot of
those are the things that matter the
good [ __ ] will stick it'll rise to the
top and that's the same with the the
show that's not to say that every guest
has something interesting right all of
the people that i bring on have got
something interesting but maybe it's not
the right time or maybe it doesn't
resonate or whatever with me
just
all i do is focus on
what's the stuff that i can't not
remember
that's it
oh look i'm going to leave you there i
appreciate the hell out of all of you uh
i feel like 450k is probably not going
to be far away so we'll do this again
soon right
hi
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace